I'll
fix that later.
Please remember to subscribe to the channel as
well and thumbs up that video if you
get an opportunity and you enjoy it. It
really helps other people discover and find this
content as well.
Today we're gonna take a look at n8n
and to do that I am joined by
Tanny Pant. Hello Tanny. How are you?
Very well. How are you doing today?
Yeah, I'm alright. I did pretty well. The
weather's nice in Scotland which is a rare
feat especially at this time of the year.
And this is my last day of work
this week. I'm just gonna give you far
too much information though. My last day of
work this week there's no streams tomorrow, I'm
off for my birthday so I'm quite happy
about that too and of course I'm very
happy to be joined by you to cover
n8n.
Do you wanna just take a moment to
tell us about you, who you work for,
and and then we'll dive into the to
today's content.
Sure. So I'm Tane, and I'm the head
of developer relations at n a ten. And
what that entails is, like, I have been
working on several exciting things recently, like helping
our community automate a lot of really cool
stuff and help them unleash their productivity.
I've been involved in the world of open
source and DevRel for almost six years now.
And before this, I've been involved with the
Mozilla Foundation on several tracks. And I've also
published books on some of my favorite topics
like Firefox OS, WebVR,
and virtual assistance on Raspberry Pi.
And
since I have a background in computer science,
I'm very familiar with programming and software development.
And a while back, I learned about the
LEGO programming language.
Have you heard of it, David?
I
mean, I consider myself quite well versed when
it comes to esoteric programming languages, but I
must say I did not know the LEGO
programming language.
Okay. So what they do is they use
it in their Mindstorms products,
and,
those robots can be move made to move
in certain patterns by connecting these preprogrammed
blocks of movements.
So when I saw that, I recognized the
value it provides in reducing
the effort of doing things by abstracting the
complexity of making a robot physically move.
And then last year, I came across n
a 10, and something clicked in the back
of my head. I could totally see the
genius of having a node based system with
nodes for concepts like conditional logic along with
products and services to automate things.
And, this for me was like finding Lego
for the real world.
So as a developer advocate, a tool like
n8n provides immense value to me to be
able to build real world scalable demos so
quickly. And as an educator, I need to
be able to teach newcomers into tech about
how things work with the support of node
based thinking.
And for me, no code is about empowerment,
and n eight n allows me to do
just that.
So I can introduce n eight ten, shortly.
So n eight ten is an extendable
workflow automation tool,
and it has a fair code distribution model,
which means that n a n a 10
will always have visible source code, be available
to self host, and allow you to add
custom functions, logic, and apps.
And its node based approach makes it very
versatile,
enabling you to connect anything to everything.
And our mission is to give everyone who
uses a computer technical superpowers.
Okay. So there are a few words there
that I heard that kinda give away a
lot of flavor about what any n is
then. So I'm gonna try and pick a
few out. Like, you mentioned no code. Can
we just talk about what no code is?
Sure.
So no code is the ability to build
services,
products,
or or workflows without writing any code.
So
let's say I don't know, like, every what
happens to me often living in Berlin is
I go out, I forget my umbrella,
and it rains, and I arrive in the
office drenched.
So, you know, having something as simple as,
you know, running a cron job
every
morning, let's say, at eight, and getting weather
information and getting a text saying, like, hey.
You should take an umbrella today because it's
gonna rain. So even as simple as workflows
like these, you can completely build them without
writing any code.
Okay. So that's
really cool. People that
not guess, people
don't need code to build these workflows, which
great. But you also the other thing that
stuck out to me when you mentioned this
was you said extendable workflow automation. So I'm
assuming I have the option to write code
as well?
You do. You do. So
extensible actually covers different facets of n a
10.
One of them being, yes, we have a
function node so in that you can write
JavaScript code. So in case there's something
that isn't available in n eight n, you
can write JavaScript code for making that happen,
be that data transformation
or something else.
Then also, like, as I mentioned, n eight
n is on GitHub. It's source code visible,
and
you can write your own custom notes if
you know TypeScript.
I've been doing that since the last week
and it's a lot of fun I must
say.
Okay. Cool. Let me pull up the the
website then. Though
right away I can see, you know, the
fair code, the extendable workflows. I can see
the number one product of the week. So
you know, people are obviously liking this and
then using it and that's backed up by
you know, you've got 10,000 stars and a
quite a high ratio of forks as well.
So it sounds like it's maybe a really
good project for people to contribute to as
well and I'm just gonna make that assumption
based on that like,
and JavaScript is such a prominent language in
TypeScript, so that's pretty cool too. Now,
what are some of the I'm assuming that
you use any n on a daily basis,
I'm assuming that your colleagues use any n
on a daily basis. Can you maybe just
give us a little bit of insight into
some of the tasks that you're automating with
this tool?
Sure.
So we're using n eight n in quite
a lot of different ways.
So we use
this chatting
platform called Mattermost.
So for those of you who are unaware,
it's an open source alternative to Slack,
and
they allow you to create custom slash commands
similar to the Slack ecosystem, I'd say.
So we have a lot of different things
like we use a slash call command that
sends the other people in the company the
link to the whereby room of the person
who issued the command,
and, whereby is a video conferencing service that
we use.
Then we have
a slash GitHub command. So sometimes, you know,
there's people contributing to the project
or,
making some pull requests and so on. And
this helps us get information about the GitHub
users, like, maybe their Twitter or their email
so, you know, we can reach out to
them and thank them for supporting us.
It also helps us, like, reduce unnecessary
communication at times. Like, one of our colleagues
is working on the n eight n cloud.
It's the hosted version of n eight n.
And, you know, we used to ping him
from time to time, like, hey. How's it
going? How many people have signed up? And
this is unnecessary
overhead. Right? And what we did was we
created a slash SaaS command, which gets all
the metrics about n eight ten cloud. So,
you know, the conversations have to be more
meaningful, like, oh, I have a specific question.
And, like, something really interesting we did recently,
was
so I'm working on me and my team
is working on creating the documentation
for different nodes in n8n.
And
so when we started doing this, n8n already
had somewhere around 30,
hundred and 40 nodes.
And
we add notes rather quickly. Like, if you
take a look at our change talk, we
have been adding notes at a great velocity.
So, you know, like, we are creating
documentations,
but new notes are getting added. And sometimes,
like, you're going on vacations and you have
no idea, okay, which ones have been documented,
which ones haven't. So what we did was
we also created slash docs command,
but this also runs as a cron job
every Monday. So what it does is it,
gets information on what are all the nodes
in n eight n through a GraphQL endpoint,
and that data is being fed fed through
Strapi.
We get that data,
and the name of the nodes sort of
correlates to the doc URL of the documentation.
So we use HTTP request node to see
if we get a four zero four. If
it did, then that documentation doesn't exist. So
it sort of gives us a list. Okay.
These nodes need to be documented.
So that's like one of the
ways like some of the ways that we
have been using in it and for.
Nice. There's there was a lot of practical
examples there. Things that I can immediately relate
to and I'm thinking, wow. Like, I could
we could use that in in in our
team for sure.
So
pop quiz then. You mentioned there were a
30 nodes. How many are there today?
That's a good question.
I'd I'd take a chance and say around
200.
Okay. So if I had I'm just gonna
click around on the docs now because I'm
I'm I'm curious.
This is the node library here.
Yes. This one?
Yeah. Alright. Okay. There's a fair few and
I'm not gonna count them. I'm not gonna
count them. I'll just say you're close enough
that it seems plausible.
Alright. I think what we should do is
just get hands on it and start and
start playing with n8n. So
as a newcomer to the project how
I was gonna say how they get started
but as always there is a getting started
part of the documentation.
I'm just gonna assume and click please feel
free to say stop, you're going the wrong
way or whatever but
MPX. No.
I'm I'd
say I'm comfortable writing JavaScript but the tooling
has always kind of eluded me. I believe
MPX is just a way to execute
random, not random, but you know, some arbitrary
package from NPM as long as I provide
the name is that's that's correct. Right?
Yeah. And once you close it, all the
data would be lost though. So it's it's
sort of like running
on a docker container without any persistence.
Okay. And I can see we have docker
as an option too and we have the
ability just to globally install it with npm.
Alright. Yeah. I think I may actually had
done this at some point when I was
curious. So let me grab my terminal.
Move over here.
Thank
you.
So
let's see what happens.
Okay. Maybe I haven't done it because the
list is installing. We
put out a release yesterday, so perfect. You'll
have the latest version.
Oh, wow. So we're playing with bleeding edge
as well. Excellent.
And
I'm very exciting because I I added three
nodes to yesterday's release, so hey.
Three new nodes. Alright. I mean,
when you say that it's easier, right, to
add a new node.
What do you mean?
So let me me actually rephrase that question.
How simple is it to add a new
node? Are we talking like 10 lines of
code, 50 lines of code, any dependencies? I
guess it all depends on the node. Can
you maybe just pick one of the ones
that you released yesterday and tell us how
you went about it?
Alright. So yesterday we released Orbit.
Do you know about Orbit?
Yeah. The DevRel kind of metrics community Yes.
Exactly.
Yeah. Exactly.
So I'd say, like, my
first node was
for Apache Kafka.
And, like, that took me around three hours
to build it.
And there was a reason because, like, I
hadn't written JavaScript in around one and a
half or two years.
I have never worked with TypeScript before.
And
so Like, that was a bit of a
bit of an effort there, but like it
really depends on
yeah. I
mean, I'm hearing such contradictory stuff there. You
haven't written JavaScript or TypeScript in a year
and a half. Kafka is a bit complex,
but a software
and you're saying that three hours was long
for implementing that. I mean, seems really quick.
Like if I were able to build a
node for any end in under three hours,
I'd be pretty shocked for myself. And you
seem to be like, no, it should have
been faster.
So
yeah. Like, it really depends on two things.
It's like how familiar are you with this
whole JS ecosystem.
So TypeScript was a bit new for me.
So that could have definitely
increased the speed of development there. And second
is the API or the service that you
are implementing,
how well documented it is.
So
just as an example, what we did
so I I created this over the weekend.
Right? And
I was implementing it using the Kafka JS
library.
So I was having a chat with one
of my colleagues in the office, and I
was telling him, like, hey. I did this
on the weekend. Really excited about it.
And he was like, oh, how long did
you take? We had the same conversation.
And then he said, like,
can we should take shall we take a
look at how quick it can be?
And I was like, okay. We should definitely
do that. So we picked up Google Translate.
Right? And
also depends on how complete the note is.
So Kafka, for instance okay. Like, you just
send data to it, to a Kafka broker,
but Orbit, for instance, had a lot of
different endpoints. You can create
crew member, crew to node, post a lot
of different things.
So translate, we said, okay. You put in
a text query,
it translates it to the target language. That's
it. It does one thing. Right?
That took me about twenty minutes to implement.
So, like, at that point, I had played
a bit around with n eight n, was
a bit familiar with, like, how the notes
look like.
And,
yeah, like, basically,
how how TypeScript essentially works. So it can
be very quick. But then, again, like, I've
heard from my colleagues who have been working
on this is, like, it really boils down
to how well
documented, implemented the API itself is because that
can make a lot of difference in the
development time as well. Yeah. That makes sense
to me. Definitely.
Okay. We can talk more about the, you
know, contributing notes a little bit later. Let
let's cover some of the basics first. So
I've done that install. Does that mean I
can just run n a n?
Yes. So there's two ways that you can
do that for sure.
You can this will run n a 10,
and there's another way of writing running n
a 10. Is it and that's with tunnel.
So,
basically, that is n a 10 space start
space hyphen hyphen tunnel. And what that does
is oh, it start without the hyphen.
Dash dash tunnel. And then hyphen hyphen. Yeah.
So
what this would do is is, like, if
you are using a trigger node, which so,
like, if you're using a Telegram trigger, for
instance, or a GitHub trigger, your n eight
n instance needs to be accessible from the
Internet.
So this will use the local tunnel
and make it accessible to the Internet. But
this is really for
development and testing purposes.
Great. Okay. So we're anticipating that we may
do something that requires
something on the internet to speak back to
our n a n, so we're adding the
tunnel parameter.
Yes. I think I understood that right. Okay.
So waiting for tunnel, I suppose I should
let on the network.
I can just push oh,
I bet it opens over here. Oh, it
didn't. Wow.
That was good. Okay.
No, I'm just every time I've opened a
browser when I'm on the stream it moves
over there and I have to go and
fetch it but we're good. Anyway, not important.
Awesome. So what do we have
here? I see a draggy thing. I see
yeah. I figured that was gonna do something
there. Oh, code that.
I'm assuming with my naive knowledge here, this
is an empty workflow.
It is an empty workflow. So this is
a new workflow. And
what we are looking at this whole screen
is
called the editor UI. So it's essentially an
empty canvas for you to design your workflows.
Yeah. Alright.
I'm just gonna keep executing that because it's
cool. Like alright.
So I So we start off
Sorry. On your go, Tanny.
Yeah. I I was mentioning, like, we start
off with the start node.
Like, all workflows would have a start node
even if it's used or not.
So in case you're using a workflow that's
being called with a trigger node,
you can safely ignore it.
Okay. But if you are manually executing
workflow,
the first node needs to be connected to
the start node.
Right. Okay. So that so when I drag
this over here, I get to create a
node thing and I can just
pick any of these that I want. Right?
And it's gonna Yes. Do something. Okay. What
is a a good note then for us
just to do something that is visual and
we can see it working?
Okay.
That's a very tough question.
Let's do HTTP
request node. I was just thinking that so
good.
So
we have
my friend wrote this app and I've used
this a few times now on a stream
called Rbox.app that just gives us a web
hook endpoint. So I guess we we can
send something to this.
Yeah. We can for sure. We can. Let's
do it. See plans
coming already.
So let me see if I can work
this out. So no authentication.
I am gonna send
a put because
why not. I'm gonna drop in that URL.
I'll just ignore that for now. I don't
know if it I don't think it will
do anything.
Can
I send?
Yeah. Okay.
So I can just click add parameter.
Can I just send JSON?
You can. So you can send so this
would basically create a key value pair
in body parameters
if you use this.
But also if you click on JSON
yeah. So you could also then add JSON
in there
in the body parameters.
Yeah. You can enter add JSON there. There
we go.
Now I feel at home. Right.
Cool that tab key worked. There's a feature
request.
Name,
David.
Let the
it's gonna be my birthday. I'll add my
age
and
we'll see
website.
I know this is completely unimportant,
but I'm just gonna do it.
So I just click close. Yeah.
If I'm not mistaken, you'd probably have to
send that as parameter because this is
like, send that as a JSON object and
this right now is like a string.
But let's see what the notes says if
you execute it. So I I was just
under the assumption and when I click this
Mhmm. I was just gonna do raw JSON
which this let's try it. Alright. Well, I
think it can happen it can break. Now
I also see settings. I always like to
click buttons so
oh, I can pick the color.
I'm a sucker for these weird tweaks as
well. Let's go with that.
Execute once, retry and fail. Cool, that sounds
good.
Continue and fail.
I guess that will become more prominent or
important when we have more than one step
to our workflow.
So am I done? Can I just close
this again?
And this is that's it, right? That's my
workflow.
Okay. Yeah.
And I just click go.
Nice.
So you can
Okay.
Tada.
Alright. I'm easily easily pleased. Perfect. Cool.
I like it.
Okay. So
that was easy.
So what the HTTP request is quite useful
for is basically,
like, it's we used to call it the
Swiss Army Knife node for n a 10.
So, like, we have nodes for a lot
of services.
But let's say you have a service with
the rest API,
and we don't have a node for that.
You can always use the HTTP request node.
You can make authentication with it, send it
different parameters, even some binary files, and so
on. So if we don't have a node
for something, you can always use the HTTP
request node for making that happen.
Okay.
So should we
add
another node
or
do we save this workflow?
Like, right now it says workflow is not
saved. So I'm assuming if I close this
and go away, it it disappears
like
If I give you a warning and if
you still leave,
then it goes How confident are you just
gonna give me a warning if I had
closed tab, will it warn me or
I'd I'd I'm very confident here.
Hitch. Yeah.
Oh, yes. Okay.
Yeah.
Cancel. Okay. So can I save the how
do I save it? Let's see.
If you go on on the extreme left
workflows.
Save it. Okay. So basic
h t t p So this
feature with
if your workflow is not saved, it gives
a warning.
It was implemented in the latest version.
No. Really? Last week. The version last week.
Yeah. Point nine one.
And you were still confident that it was
gonna give me a warning. Nice. Okay. Yeah.
I was I was told I I I
tried refreshing page after it was released. I
closed on tabs. I've lost a couple of
workflows because it didn't give me a warning
before. So I was I tried it all
the different ways and yeah. Like
Alright. What what's this active button for?
So active button is useful when you are
using a trigger note. So in n8n, you
have essentially two different kinds of notes.
So it's like trigger notes and regular notes.
And I feel a bit bad about calling
them regular notes. They're quite extraordinary.
But yeah. Okay.
So the trigger notes essentially start a workflow
and supply initial data. So a workflow can
contain multiple trigger nodes, but with each execution,
only one of them will execute. So this
is because the other trigger nodes would not
have any input
as they are, like, the nodes which are
which are the starting of a workflow's execution.
So an example of that could be a
cron node. So
cron node, if you say, run every Monday
or, like, the example I gave in the
beginning, like, run every morning at 8AM.
So there's a couple of if you click
on add cron time, there's a couple of
options you can choose. Like, every day, you
can select
every minute.
And, like, you can also add a custom
cron expression, I suppose it's called. I always
use a website to build them if I
need to do that.
But yeah. Does this zero zero just mean
every error, every minute?
No. So it says every day at zero.
So Ah, okay. 12AM.
Twelve AM. Yes. Can I just star?
Like, the actual oh, no. That didn't work.
Okay. Yeah. Maybe I should just do
oh, there we go. Every minute. It was
easier than I thought it was gonna be.
Alright. Let's just So
yeah. So these are like the trigger notes.
Go ahead. Go ahead.
Yeah.
Is that enabled now?
No. So you need to like, if you
click on active,
you don't need to connect it. So it's
the it would be the first node in
a workflow.
So you can now connect it to the
HTTP request node
or to the small box on the left
of the node.
To the left. Yes. You
can actually disconnect it with the start node
or you can keep it. Doesn't wouldn't matter.
So I guess what I what I'm thinking
here then is that with I can add
multiple trigger nodes
and they will all be responsible for checking
off this HTTP request when they get triggered.
Right? So I can say Yes. Send this
HTTP request when all of these when any
of these things happen, and I could just
be any arbitrary number of trigger notes that
I want. Right?
Yep. Yep.
But, like, only one would execute at a
time, but, yeah, you can have multiple triggers
as well. So now that you activated the
workflow,
this would, trigger this query every minute, I
suppose. That's the setting you you added.
Yeah.
Well, I don't know why this isn't refreshing.
Try again. Well, I don't think it's just
it's just not saying anything yet. Okay.
So I guess how okay. There's there's my
next question then. Can I view the
events or
soon as I said that, I've seen that?
I'm assuming that's execution. It's just gonna show
me. Yes. Okay.
So this was my
was this my manual trigger?
No. Yes.
So if you take a look at this
so more this trigger.
So before this, like, I'd show you one
thing. Oh, yeah. Sure. Go for it. Sorry.
I'm getting scatterbrained here. No worries.
If you go on the left side, under
workflows, there's a setting there's settings.
So you can have
settings for each workflow.
So you can send, like, your time zone.
You can also set what sort of
data executions would be saved. So it's like,
error as execution
or
success.
So, like, you'd have to specify. So the
a lot of defaults is yes. Yep. So
it says basically here, save manual executions.
Default, it's set to no. So that was
the
cron node trigger that.
Oh, okay. Alright. So if I click save
on that and do a manual execution,
that means then I come here. Yeah. We
see the manual and I'll see that my
cron one then has run twice at twenty
nine zero seven and twenty eight zero eight.
So yeah, roughly a minute apart. So let's
see if I can.
Oh yeah. Okay.
It's working.
I was thinking you for some reason that
you said every second, but it was every
minute. So checks out. Yeah. Yep. And there's
another one off. Right. Okay. I could probably
turn that off now.
Yep.
Click this.
Or you can also deactivate the workflow on
top right.
You don't need to disconnect it.
Because this would still trigger the workflow every
minute,
but nothing would happen because nothing is connected
to the current node.
Oh, like, oh, I can turn off the
trigger with that little pause thing. Right?
So this deactivates the node. So to, like,
turn off the active state of the workflow
on the top right, you have the active
button. You can toggle that.
Alright. Okay. So I can turn off the
entire workflow, but I can also just pause
and turn off individual triggers as well if
I want.
Yep.
Alright,
save.
Okay, cool, I like it. I can already
start to see how this is forming the
building blocks of like the bigger automation or
workflow things that I would probably wanna do
with this tool. That's really cool, I'm happy.
What do we what should we take a
look at next?
Should we get data from a rest endpoint
and do something with it? I mean, it's
as difficult, but I'll give it a shot.
It's easy.
Alright. So So New workflow. Teach me.
So let's use this API I discovered a
few months back. It's called the cocktail d
b API. Let's let's learn to make some
cocktails while we are learning about n a
10 as well.
Alright. Cocktail d b API.
And if you search for random on the
page, command f.
Look up a random cocktail.
So let's copy that.
Alright. Okay. So we get some JSON back.
So I'm assuming
you're gonna want me to add
HTTP
request?
Exactly.
And we're gonna do a get request to
that URL
and
I hook this up
and then hit execute.
Okay. So
You can double click it? Double click it?
Alright. That was my next Okay.
So we can actually see the JSON.
Ah, there we go. That's much better. Nice.
Okay. So
I'm assuming
in fact, why don't what what do we
do next? I I don't wanna assume. I'll
get it wrong.
Okay.
So what we can do is
shall we create
we can do a lot of things with
this.
Should we play around with Telegram maybe?
Or or would you like to us to
make a graphic for this?
So What should we do?
I mean, well, right now, I want a
cocktail,
but I'm assuming any n can't do that.
Why I mean, what I think what I'm
okay. I can see use cases where I
wanna had an API, I wanna fetch some
data.
How do I pack out bits of this
data that I think are important? Is that
just a new node? How does any n
help me dissect that JSON?
Cool.
So what we can do is add a
set node after this.
Okay. So I can just go boop and
then You can also press on tab
that opens up the
Nice.
Okay. Can what's what's the what's the set
node?
So set node, can set different variables.
These could be new variables, like new JSON
entry points.
But also you can click on keep only
set. So only the values that you set
in this node would be passed forward in
the workflow.
So all the data that's being passed to
the workflow is in JSON. So
CocktailDB returned a lot of things, a lot
of
values. So all of that would be passed
along in the workflow,
but we can change that with a set
node. Can also use a function node, but
easier
the no code way. Okay.
So just add value. I say I want
a string and then the proper name. Is
that gonna help me fill in that property
name?
Like You can call it whatever you want.
Let's maybe like
cocktail name.
Yeah. Let's take the cocktail name. Yeah. That
makes sense.
Okay.
And how
how do I propagate that value from that
JSON we got in the previous node?
Right. So on the gears icon next to
the value field, if you click on it,
add expression. So it's gonna be a dynamic
value which is gonna change every time you
execute the workflow because it's a random API.
And I'll let you find that.
I'm just clicking away here. I'm I'm quite
happy. So
let's
see.
ID drink. Oh, no.
That's not a category. Okay. So we have
a category and we got this drink here.
So let's get the name. I think, yeah,
rum server. That's the name.
Click close
and
I'm gonna just run this because I like
clicking that.
Double click this.
So it still returns all the information. So
we'd have to click on keep only set
inside the node.
You can also execute the note from execute
note button on the top on the right.
Yeah.
So it just returns this. Alright.
Let's get the description.
I'm gonna change this actually. That seems a
little bit redundant.
Now we're gonna add the expression and I'm
gonna just jump through.
Category actually was what I want, wasn't it?
Not descriptions.
Let me fix that.
I'll call it I'm gonna call it type
of drink. Let's see what happens.
Alright. I win a party drink called as
the Madori Zinger. I'll take two. Thanks.
Alright. Nice. That's nice. I like it.
So
let's tackle, we have a viewer question which
I'll pop up on the screen.
So SM has asked, is it possible to
implement cloud functions?
Basically you call an endpoint, execute a workflow
and return the final result to the original
API call.
Let me
Yeah. Okay. So I think I understand the
question.
If you understand it, by all means go
because you I I do. Alright. Cool. So
yes, we can do that.
Should we do that?
Yeah. Let's do it.
Cool. Okay. So what we do is we
add a webhook node and we haven't talked
about it before,
but let's add it. So it's a Let
me save my working The cocktail.
Alright. So we're gonna add a
web hook.
Oh, is that actually It should be in
the trigger.
Yeah. Yeah.
So what we can do here is okay.
Let's take a look at this first. There's
a couple of options.
So if you click on the webhook URLs
on the top,
it's a pink color,
orange.
And we have two
different webhook URLs, so production and test.
So the difference between the two is
a test webhook URL
is
to register the webhook, you click on execute
workflow.
The webhook stays active for hundred and twenty
seconds, and then it stops.
So
the benefit of using a test
webhook URL is essentially
you get to see all the data that's
coming in and it helps you design your
workflow.
So when you're done designing,
then you use the production webhook and set
it to active.
So
Got it. Okay. So that okay. That's got
this comes back to that dash dash tunnel
we used. Right? So what that dash dash
tunnel was doing, I think I understand a
bit more now. It's opening a connection to
n8n cloud,
which is giving me the ability to do
this kind of thing. Got it. Okay.
So what and like we have different authentication
options if you wanna password protect your endpoint
and like a bot as well. So let's
do one thing.
On the response mode at the bottom,
let's set it to okay. Let's let's not
do anything. That's fine.
Let's copy the
test webhook URL. You just click on it.
Yes. Perfect. You can close this or click
on execute node.
Or can I just curl this?
You can. Yeah. Or you can also open
it in your browser, whichever way you prefer.
But you'll have to execute workflow first because
we're gonna be using
oh, you'd have to save the workflow first.
My bad. So whenever you're using a trigger
node,
it saves the ID. And for that, we
need to save the workflow first.
Alright. I'll call that fast.
I'll pop this open again. We hit execute.
And now you can make a code request.
Let me close that.
Or yeah.
So you got the message. Workflow got started,
and you get the data
from the endpoint.
So now what you can do is essentially,
for instance,
copy the
STDP request node which got the cocktail information,
connect that to webhook,
add a set node,
and in the response type, we add
last node. So every time you execute it,
it's gonna send the data that you sent
in set node, and that way you create
a sort of API endpoint with an a
d m.
Okay.
Right.
So
let me try and stitch something together here
then.
We received a request. I'm
gonna do something with that request. Right? So
let me see what what have we got?
Weather information maybe?
Need to get API key for that though.
That's
We spoke about it here. Right? That's that's
here. So can I Yep? Send a curl
request with a color code and have it
change the color of my lights behind me
then?
Yep.
Then respond
with we'll we'll add something that responds with
to satisfy that functions of the service thing
as well.
Perfect.
Secret
stuff, hold on. Let me move to my
secret layer.
Alright.
Please standby. I should have like some hold
music available shouldn't I for
for a moment like this.
What do I need?
So in case
you're having troubles finding where to get the
credentials,
there's also a link to our documentation which
tells what credentials you need to get and
where you'd find them.
So I think
I I think I got them right. Hold
on. Let's test it. So can I
what the what is the late ID?
Can I get different So this
probably isn't connected correctly because this should auto
populate?
Oh, right. Okay. So
you can press the pencil button next to
it.
So then need to
Oh, it's popping up something.
Yeah. I trust you.
Did
you set the
URL for
the redirect URI
in Philips Hue?
Because
you'd need to use the
Oh, it's an n a m r okay.
Sorry. Because you're running with the tunnel right
now.
Okay. So
let me try one more time.
So for generally, for authentication
or authentication and so on, you don't use
to need need
to use tunnel.
But since you're using tunnel,
crashed n a n. So I just re
there we go.
Okay.
So we're back to this bit.
That's
changed again, hasn't it?
Probably.
Alright. Hold on. One more update.
Save.
Okay. That's saved. So I'm gonna pop this
thing open again.
If this doesn't work, I might just drop
the tunnel thing for a second.
Why is that not working?
So
is is this
is the
or or three direct URI that you get
is same in Philips Hue
when you created the OAuth app?
You know, I'm just gonna do this on
the screen so that you can see because
I'm sure it's me that something wrong.
And then what I'll do is I'll just
delete that little secret tokens later.
If Venom does decide to change the color
of my bulbs then so be it.
Let's see. Okay. So
create new
year two
and
my client ID.
So
my client secret.
Rawkode
live.
I had copied
this.
Should this be changing every time I restart
or is that just static? Generally,
no.
But if like
you started an instance when the other one
wasn't properly closed, the previous one would still
be occupied,
so then it would give you a new
one. But if you close n8n and restart
it, it shouldn't change.
Not yet. So
oh, did you already paste the
or it's called back URL in your Philips
Hue app?
Yeah. So I updated
Philips Hue to this URL.
So next to OAuth where it says not
connected in the OAuth section. Mhmm.
Yes. Yeah. You need to click here.
Okay.
Alright. So we think this is a tunnel
bug
potentially or I've just broken it during the
initial setup. I'm not really sure. So what
I'm gonna do is cheat.
Not cheat.
I'm gonna spin it up a third.
Let's try that again.
Reload.
Okay. So now I've got a different OAuth
callback.
Save.
And
go.
Hey. Okay.
That works.
Now, ah, there we go. So I can
do my office. We'll do the office strip
lates.
And
I guess hue would be the color.
Hue would be the shade. I I imagine.
Okay. Let's take a look.
Yeah.
I'll just pick a number.
Okay.
Did it change?
No. I think, like, some shading change.
Let's
take a look at the ad field.
What do we have here?
So do we have alert effect? Let's try
alert effect maybe first.
Which one? Sorry?
Alert effect.
If you go on the top,
yeah, you can try this
and execute node.
Oh,
it's flashing.
Cool.
Let me change this.
I don't really know what this number is.
So I think let me take a look
at the I can pop open the Philips
Hue documentation.
The link was right there in front of
me.
Mhmm.
I try it again.
Alright. Okay. That works. I'm happy with that.
So Okay. So it's a value called
hue
that you have to add to change color.
Yeah. I added the hue, but the color
I mean, it seems to be numeric.
So it's a value if you click on
the tooltip next to the field,
it will mention like is wrapping value between
zero and sixty five thousand five thirty five.
Oh, so my technical numbers probably just weren't
doing anything.
Yeah.
Zero is red for instance, if you wanna
try that.
What blue?
Blue.
46920.
4 9 10.
4 6 9 2 0.
Alright. Okay.
It's not changing the color.
So I think we should turn off the
alert effect.
So that would go to
yeah.
Let's try a different light. Maybe it's just
that. Let's see.
Update. Let's try it. So I'm reading
as green.
Okay.
Let's
let's move on. The the key thing is
cool. I like the alert. I'll play around
with that color thing for sure.
Now We use this for
yeah. We use it for when we got
10,000 get up stars to flash the lights
around the office.
Nice.
Now what does that mean for this web
hook then? Now that I'm not in tunnel
mode, should I go back to tunnel mode?
You don't need to. You could still make
calls locally
because you'd be calling to local host.
So if you open the webhook URL, you
just notice
the name changed.
Let's just add a new one
to trigger
webhook.
And what do I get now?
Oh yeah. Never on local host. Okay. So
test,
copy,
execute
and then
that should just work as last time. Yeah.
Okay. Cool. Yes.
But of course, this time it wouldn't be
reachable from the internet
because you're running it locally.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. I understand the trade
off I've just made there by removing the
tunnel thing.
Got it. But that's fine. Yeah. I'm okay
with that. So we now have this web
hook or the ability to start something here
and then we wanna do something. So
How about getting weather details?
Weather sounds good.
Oh, so I need credentials.
So do you have a API key for
this?
For open weather map? For open. Let
me quickly take a look. I can send
you one.
I'll send you in the chat.
I'll move it over here
and then bring it back as if nothing
happened.
So
open
weather
map. The terminal is acting like a curtain
here.
Alright.
There we go. So
I now have that credential say thank you
for that. That allows me to oh, let's
do a forecast. That looks cool.
Kelvin or met let's go by metric.
Okay. So setting name,
I live in Paisley,
just outside of Glasgow.
Yeah.
Okay. So let's see. Can I
let me see if I can work this
one out? So
let's
use this webhook
to receive a parameter.
Okay. I don't know how to do that.
But it won't matter, will it? Right? I
can do that here
and if I remove the paisley,
add an expression and the
nodes web hook output data.
So I'm do I need to send a
payload to that so it knows that that's
a potential field?
Yes. Alright. Okay. So let's just use a
query parameter
and say set it equals
I'll send main for now.
So you need to execute
the workflow so that the web hook registers
again.
Okay.
So
click
and then
send. Okay.
So now it knows there's this potential field
that it's gonna receive
and the query setting. Okay.
And now I'm hoping if I come back
to this expression
thing
You could just click on it
on the city field. Yeah.
Then we can see.
There we go. See, I knew it was
gonna work like that.
Alright.
So that sets it to whatever I send
and then I can execute.
And that's gonna get me the weather forecast
for that set as it gets passed in.
Okay. So now back to the question that
we received then is how do I respond
to this webhook with the weather forecast information?
So now if you go on the webhook
node, what we've
the webhook node, if you open it again
Yep. Yep.
For the response mode, now we wanted to
send the data from the last node that
executed.
So
that's fine. First entry JSON is okay. Oh,
yep.
And we execute it.
And let's
do in the other browser window.
And
we can, of course, use set note to
clean this information, so we are only sending
out what is actually needed.
But yep. So to answer some question, like,
you can use any 10 workflows as an
API endpoint as well.
Okay. So so far when I've been running
this, I've had to execute
for that to work. Like, so this won't
work now. Is that right?
Yes. It wouldn't because we haven't activated the
workflow.
Ah, so two things.
First, we'd activate it
and now you'll yep. Go ahead. And now
you'll need to make calls to the production
webhook URL.
So if you open the webhook node again,
webhook URLs,
let's use the production now.
So now you wouldn't have to press execute
anymore.
Okay. So
that error is expected because I never sent
one, but let's talk about how we fix
that too. Let's do Paris.
Okay.
Can I make it handle
the the error better and return something to
the user that says, hey, you you need
to provide a query parameter here? Sure.
So what we can do is place a
if node in front of it. So we
can say, you know, if there is no
query
then
prior given error.
Okay. So I guess what we're looking for
is if string
I'm just gonna keep using this cog thing
because it seems quite handy.
Okay. So
I'm assuming let's see if I got this
right. So this is in if city,
How would I do
not contain? No.
How can I check for the existence of
it?
So what you can do is use
Okay. With a blank. Would that work?
Let's try that.
I haven't tried it before. Let's try it.
You'd need to,
yeah, close this.
Oh, yep. Oh, so not equal, it says.
Yeah.
Okay. Oh, so now I can just add
a false.
Okay. So that So that could be a
set node. So I think what I need
to do is
remove this.
So
because I've got ever equals blank. So if
that is false, I've probably done that the
wrong way around now. And then here,
so how can I just return
a random string?
We use the set node again. Set node.
Yep.
And let's add a that's yep. Perfect.
String.
It's called the name.
It's the header. And
then we can say You're a city. There's
no city.
I'll be about Amigo.
There we go.
Close.
So
let's see if I've broken it first. Right?
So let's You'll have to see if the
workflow again.
Oh.
Thanks for keeping me honest. Let's see.
Save.
And it's active.
Okay.
Let's do London.
Sorry. Let's get that the wrong way around.
I'll need to I don't know. I'll check
my logic on that to make sure I
understand that correctly before we
and that crossing the streams will annoy me,
so let's do this.
Right.
Save
and then hopefully London works.
Yes.
And then let's remove it.
Okay.
It didn't like that.
Okay. So I think we should activate the
workflow again.
Let's deactivate and activate it again.
Okay. Let's try that out. Try again?
Yeah.
Error.
Okay.
So It seems like I think
it it's expect I'm assuming
right now that it expects its value to
this.
Maybe I just so I just get something
wrong. Let's delete this. Right?
Let's try.
Well, there's an option. Right? So we have
the
continue and fail, retry and fail. Maybe there's
something I could do there. But let's see
if I can get this working.
String. So
one thing we haven't chatted about in
the expressions,
like we have been like selecting
outputs.
But if you use something within double curly
brackets, you can use JavaScript in there.
So we could also say, you know, if
the value is null or something like that.
Alright. Walk me through that. So try just
to string again?
Yeah.
And then
add expression.
Because the thing is if we are adding
an expression here,
like there is nothing to compare there.
Right. Okay. Let's
you mentioned earlier,
I can take code. Can we do that?
Yeah. We can use a function node for
that. Function?
Yes.
It's a function.
So the difference between function and function items
is the function nodes takes all the data
that's coming inside and does something with it.
Function
item
takes all the
items that are being provided to it individually
and acts on that each time.
Oh,
okay. So
I I know that I'm in code mode.
I'm feeling
a little helpless. I've lost my ad expression
with all the nice clicky clicky stuff. So
I'm not really sure what I would add
here.
Okay. So
just as an example,
all the data that's being passed
throughout the workflow is in the variable called
items.
Can we confirm that?
Or is there is there a way to
debug what items is?
Sure. Let's do it.
Console log
items.
Okay. So console log, you'd have to go
into the terminal where you're running n a
10.
Also, probably doesn't have any data right now.
Yeah. That's what I was thinking. So
alright.
So I see the Oh, the big console
log. Is gonna be activated.
Right. Because
I could just return items and that will
show me everything when I hit it. So
That's true. Yeah.
Now what happened is I think you used
the production webhook URL
and you manually executed it
so it wouldn't show the data there.
Oh, was it because I had to save
it. No.
So whenever you execute, man so all the
data that's coming in through n eight n
while the production
while the workflow is active,
the data that passes through is invisible in
the editor UI.
The data coming in from webhook is only
visible, if you are using the test webhook.
So you would use test webhook to debug
your workflows and then set it to active
to sort of move it to production, so
to speak.
Okay. Well, we kinda got what I needed
to guess. Right? Because even by just running
that on that empty code one, which is
returning items,
that's just being dropped into the body of
this request here. So I can actually see
that probably what I'm looking for is
actually just inside the query object. So
if I do
if
query
dot city
is undefined,
then
return
false.
Otherwise, I can return query dot city.
So the thing is like how you are
handling data in n8n, it always have to
be an array.
So the function
always returns an array.
So
you would have something like
an array, like, two brackets, square brackets.
Mhmm.
No. No. At at return or it could
be here.
And then you'd have
sort of
braces
inside it because that's gonna be a object.
And JSON,
You'd have to write JSON.
So the thing is how the
data structure of n8n
is
is particular.
Alright. I think I understand.
So let's assume I do this
and then down here
I do
because we know it exists here. I do
query dot city. So based on my naive
understanding right now, this this
code note and I'm gonna just test it.
This one worked though. Yeah.
It won't work. No.
I didn't save it. So let me save
and
oh yeah, that's the test mode.
Let me run it here.
Well, workflow to there. Yeah, you're right. Okay.
I should have listened to you the first
time.
So
what did I get wrong there? Because my
understanding is if query dot city is undefined,
which means it's not been specified,
then I can return. You said I should
return an array and then I've got JSON
inside of that, but I must have misunderstood.
Right. So you have the array
brackets like the square brackets. Mhmm. Inside it
you have to type JSON
colon and then whatever is in front of
it is fine.
Oh.
Do I need to does it have to
be like
like that? No. Just JSON is fine.
Oh, yeah. I guess actually JavaScript doesn't care.
Right? So
Okay. Alright. I understand.
And also,
is it
so JSON also needs to be under
braces?
Of course.
Alright. So
let's get that fixed.
Like that, right?
Yeah.
I'm having fun.
Okay. So I'm gonna run this again.
What did I get wrong? Okay. Let's use
the test one, right? Because that gets us
the debug and stuff that we need.
Yeah.
Oops.
So test,
copy and
So if you on the bottom, you can
stop the current webhook.
If you go out.
Yeah.
And at the bottom. Yeah.
Okay. So if I had execute here, that's
waiting for me to have the test endpoint.
That's right? Yes.
Okay. That's Send that with nothing.
Query is not defined.
So it would be if query equal to
undefined.
But query was defined.
So
if I pull this back, let's comment all
that out.
I wanna understand what I got wrong there
because when we did return,
oh it's items dot query.
Okay.
I was gonna return items but that the
existence I've been able to do that means
that what we actually wanted was that.
Items dot json
item zero dot json
dot query dot city
dot
yeah.
Okay.
Let's try that. That's the worst that could
happen. Okay. So I execute
test URL.
Where did that come from?
So it returned to default which is good.
Did the test URL change?
Oh, yeah. It returns a default
because you have something outside.
Yeah. If you open that up.
Open what up? Sorry.
Sorry. The code.
Up. Yeah. In the function node? Yeah.
So here you say, like, if item zero
dot JSON dot query is undefined,
then it sends
city as
it's a Glasgow.
And
irrespective of whatever the result is, you're also
returning
JSON dot query dot city.
So like that is in inside
the if if block.
Yeah. But I never had the web. So
that's what I don't understand there. As I
had execute here and that's supposed to wait
for a request.
Oh, I see what you're Okay. No, I've
got it.
Yeah. So what I should have done is
to execute here.
I was just triggered in the wrong node.
There we go. Right.
Because what happens is you all your webhook
node already has data. So if you're executing
the next node, it's just using the data
it already had for you to model the
data. Yeah.
And now if I pass Berlin.
Oh, I broke it again.
Okay. So I got query Berlin.
Oh, yeah. I've not hooked it up to
anything.
Although But if you open it up,
query is not defined.
Yeah. Okay. So it's just me being really
crap that is continually breaking this. So let's
fix that and then hook this up. Right?
So I can now go here
and then this could
no. We just return that. Right? So
Yeah. I'm
gonna feel confident.
I'm gonna hit save and I'm gonna go
back to production
and just ship this.
Activated.
So let's do nothing.
I
I thought I had it.
What did I get wrong? This is I
think error from the old
old execution, but now we can't. So we
can check the error if you click on
executions on the left,
extreme left.
So it says error. Now you can open
on the on the right side of the
folder icon.
Yeah.
Oh, yes. We didn't save and activate.
Okay. So
it shows you what the error is. Ah,
because the set node was referenced to the
wrong expression.
Right. So I'm dropping with the map node.
Okay. So can I just go back to
our fast example?
Right? So we'll just forget that. Let's fix
this,
which is now actually looking for
yeah. It's already telling me it's broken. So
we want the function
where's my
city?
So
the function doesn't have any output right now.
So which is why we should first build
it in test and then move to production
because we need the function node to output
data to reference it.
Alright. So I thought the return here
was me returning data.
Oh, no. But it doesn't have any data
right now. Right?
Because it's not been executed.
So all the data that's visible in the
editor UI,
it's it's gonna happen when we are using
the test webhook URL.
Correct. Right. Okay. So
So we need to give it data first
and then model it. Okay. So test, copy,
execute,
jump over here,
city,
Berlin,
which now has that information.
So I'm assuming
if I
remove expression,
add expression,
No, it's function.
Yeah.
Okay.
See you just gotta learn the learn the
way of it. Okay. So I'm definitely confident
that I'm just gonna save it to go
to production.
Are you sure?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Let's do it. Let's do
it. Let's do Paris.
Alright.
Yep. That is Paris. Let's do the set.
Glasgow,
perfect.
You did it. Yay.
Okay, I understand so much more how this
all connects together now and the web of
test and production why they're important. Like it's
all it's all starting to make sense to
me a bit more now. I like it.
Awesome.
And I actually see we have a comment
with
Harshil telling us how to do it with
the F block.
Would have been
lot but I feel like I actually I
just I understand
how this is working now by going through
that that process and connecting the dots so
awesome.
Thank you for the telling us how to
do that and at the same time I'm
glad I I kind of persevered and worked
my way through that. That was great.
Alright.
What should we do next? Yeah. Let's do
one more thing.
If you got a suggestion or should I
just pop open a sidebar and start scrolling?
What what do you think?
Should we do a telegram bot?
Yeah.
How's that? Yeah.
New workflow?
Yeah. Let's do a new workflow. Do you
use Telegram?
I do. I think I even have it
running on this Mac.
Let me check.
Perfect.
Yeah. I do. Okay.
Yeah. Just make sure I can hide all
my contacts and stuff. Okay. Okay. So what
I do?
So yeah. Let's open the telegram window then.
We can create a new bot on telegram
first.
Okay. Is that fine?
Yeah. I've never done this before and
I don't wanna reveal my number but we
should be okay.
Okay.
So we need to start a chat with
bot father.
Okay. Let me.
So
Oh, it's updating. That's okay. It's just web.
That's fine.
Oh, no. It's not. Oh, we're good. Okay.
So let's start a chat.
New secret chat.
Normal chat.
What's the name?
Botfather.
Okay.
Start. Cool. So we do start.
So I think it shows you the slash
commands. So there's one for new bot.
I was gonna see if I could make
this bigger, but I don't think we can.
We should be alright. Okay. So I do
slash bot.
Oh no. No. You take a look look.
Yeah.
Okay.
So Rawkode live.
Choose a username.
Oh, Rawkode
bot.
Okay. Okay. So you can click on the
token so that it copies it. Yep. Perfect.
And
let's
go to n a 10.
Alright. So we'll start a trigger node. Oh,
trigger trigger. Yep. I'm on it.
Perfect.
And we create the credentials for it.
Okay. So Rawkode
bot access
token
allow
do I need to drag this over? Sure.
I don't know anyway.
And star. Let's do star. Let's get everything
we sent to this bot.
Uh-huh. And similarly, like the concept we talked
about production. So here, we don't need to
provide any URL
because, like, if this node takes care of
it for us. However,
if we click on execute node,
it still stays active for hundred and twenty
seconds.
We'll need to save it first.
And if we
set the workflow as active, then it will
automatically be in production mode.
But we don't need to do it now
because we need to see the data
for modeling our workflow.
So let's execute this
and go back to the Telegram
window. Oh, failed.
Because we aren't running with tunnel.
We need the n a 10 instance to
be reachable from the web.
So n a 10 needs to run with
tunnel.
On it.
Perfect.
Okay. Refresh.
Let's go
execute.
That seems happier. And
So that just
So you must have a link.
So there must be a message.
In the message, there must be a link
to your bot
just beneath the
just above the token.
I'll put it back.
Oh, yeah.
Start. So it sends slash start,
and we got it. So we got the
first message, slash start, because that went first.
That was easy.
Okay. No.
Should we try again?
Execute.
Oh.
Yeah.
Alright, Brooke.
So what does it say?
It says webhook
cannot be activated because another one with the
same method post path
is already active.
I'll just refresh. Let's close this.
Let's just I can just enable this. So
But you won't see any data coming in
though.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Execute.
K. Let's let's create a new workflow.
So your credentials are already saved.
Alright.
New switch.
Telegram trigger.
Same credentials,
same star
x. We need to save it. We need
to save it. Yep.
It's okay. Bot two.
Pop open.
Alright.
Let's send it something.
Okay.
Go away.
There we go.
Awesome.
So can I respond?
Yep. So now you have gotten a message.
What do you say about
building
maybe we build a bot
that we say, like, send it any message
and it replies with the name of a
or recipe of a cocktail
tying in from our previous
workflow that we were doing. So we can
add http request node.
Yep.
Okay.
So
and
execute.
Get some sample data for the nice expression
thingy. Perfect. So this is And then we
do here and
A telegram note to send it.
A telegram note at the end. Oh, a
telegram note at the end. Got it. Because
we need to reply with it.
So we can select the same
credentials.
Chat ID. So we need to use expressions
here.
We get the chat ID from the telegram
trigger node.
Message ID. Right?
Yes.
Oh.
No?
I'm not sure if it's message ID or
if it's chat ID.
Alright. Or you can just click on it.
Yeah. Okay. So Let's see what else it
says.
Chat ID.
Oh, yeah. Let's do that.
Alright. So
You can delete it.
I don't know how.
Oh, if you go on the yeah. If
you click there and just use backspace,
Yeah. You can delete the expression.
Okay.
Cool.
So we need another expression to filter out
the recipe from the HTTP.
Yes. So
can
I can I filter? Yeah.
Let's have a look at this data.
Do some formatter.
And if you open the HTTP request node,
it also shows it formatted
under the JSON if you close this. Oh,
yeah. Of course it did. That's right. Okay.
Look at that. It. Yeah. That's it. If
we use another tool. So JSON.
Oh, instructions.
Okay. So we want instructions.
Instructions.
So we click here filter
and I wish I had noticed that filter
earlier. That's quite handy.
And instructions.
Done.
Alright. Cool. Let's do a execute workflow then.
And with the telegram app.
Wrong window. My computer is failing.
You're
okay, MacBook. You'll be fine. Okay. So hi.
Send me a cocktail.
So what does it say? It said shaken
not stirred. It did respond
not with the instructions I thought. So the
instructions must be depending on the cocktail you
get. Let's do it again. I bet we
get something. Okay. Another please.
We probably wanna send back the ingredients and
the instructions for it to actually make sense.
But you need to, yeah. We need to,
yeah. Execute.
Okay.
Oh, there we go. Cool. Got it. So
pour ice cream vodka and bourbon in a
glass. Nice. That's pretty sweet. I like that.
Awesome.
Very cool.
That is no
effort whatsoever.
Yeah. Yeah. What I did a few days
ago was
like, one of our community members actually inspired
me to do that was she built a
Telegram bot,
and you'd send it a image of a
receipt.
Then it uses a service called Mindi.
It sends the image to that that passes
the data out of the receipt,
adds it to Google Sheets, and also sends
a confirmation, like, oh, receipt from Leader or
whatever supermarket have you of this much amount
has been passed and added. Awesome.
Okay.
I'm impressed. I think n8n is a really
cool tool and I can already
think of stuff I wanna do with this.
Let me
Is there anything else you wanna show before
we finish up? Like
Nothing comes to mind. Okay. Is there anything
you'd like to see?
There's
loads, but you know, we are heading about
an hour and a half now. I think
what we're gonna have to do is we're
gonna have to continue this again. Like there's
so many different things I wanna play with.
I think what would be really cool though
is if I
start to put a few of these workflows
together for myself and for my team
and then identify
a
plugin they know the trigger that we need
to actually do something real and then reach
out to you and I say, why don't
we do that together? Like you can walk
me through the process of actually contributing my
own node to n8n and hopefully by then
I'll have actual workflows doing real production stuff
that we can kinda, you know, off talk
about and take it from there.
That sounds good to you? Sounds like a
plan. Yeah, perfect. Awesome.
That
was really cool. Thank you, Danny. I really
enjoyed even you know, even when things went
a little bit weird and wonderful there like
just I feel like I completely understand the
data model a little bit more and all
that. I'm looking forward to it. Thank you
for joining me today. I hope you have
a really good day and I hope this
was useful to the people watching too.
Alright. Thank you for having me. I'll speak
to you soon. Thank you again. Bye.